[MUSIC PLAYING]
APOORV SAXENA: Welcome
to this session.
Thanks for joining us.
I'm Apoorv Saxena.
I'm the product leader on
Cloud Machine Learning team.
SARA ROBINSON:
I'm Sara Robinson.
I'm a developer advocate on
the Google Cloud platform team.
APOORV SAXENA: And
here we are today
to talk about how Cloud
Machine Learning can transform
your customer
service experience.
But before I get
started, let me see
how many people were listening
to Dan Green in yesterday's
keynote.
So as a show of hands,
I'm going to ask you,
how many products and features
we released last year in 2016?
Those who believe we
released less than 200,
raise you hand please.
Between 200 to 400?
Maybe a few.
About a thousand?
No, we around
between 500 to 600.
That's the number.
So we released more than
550 products and features
last year alone.
And today, at the conference, we
released more than 50 of those.
So great momentum for us.
And this is what we're going to
talk about how, specifically,
in this session, there are three
things I want you to take away.
Number one, I want
you to understand
some of the new [INAUDIBLE] and
features that we have launched
and how they can transform
customer service.
Number two, we will walk
you to through a case
study where one of
our customers, Ocado,
is using some of these
tools to transform customer
service for their customers.
And the third one, we will
talk about a PwC case study
where a customer
is building an end
to end full service solution.
SARA ROBINSON: So Apoorv,
as a product manager,
you probably get a
ton of feedback coming
from all sorts of channels.
APOORV SAXENA: Yes.
In fact, at Google
across the board
gets more than 10,000 service
requests, customer service
touch points, on a single day.
And so as a result,
we at Google,
we believe great customer
service is an important part
of a great product experience.
So we monitor our channels not
only in the traditional email
and phone calls in terms
of customer requests,
but we also monitor
Facebook, Twitter,
and so on and so forth.
But to get a differentiated
customer service experience
is not only important to monitor
all the different channels
the customer can reach you.
It's also important to make
sure the customer request
journey is differentiated
across the lifecycle.
SARA ROBINSON: And what does
a typical customer journey
look like?
APOORV SAXENA: So
lets take an example.
Again, it varies by
company by company.
But we just did a
very high level view
of how it could look like
in a situation like this.
So on one side, you
have customers' touch
points across different
channels, as I said.
Whether it could be a phone or
an email or Twitter feed coming
in, the very first
thing you typically
do when a customer
request comes in
is try to understand
who the customer is.
So typically you will
tap into your CRM system
to understand who
the customer is.
The next level is, not
every customer request
can be prioritized
as a high priority.
So try to understand what the
priority of the request is.
And then you route that
request to the appropriate CSR.
So it's a pretty
simplified view,
but across these
four steps, you still
have huge opportunity
for machine
learning to make an impact.
Number one, on the
left of the funnel,
you will see that most
of the customer requests
are well understood if
they are coming from email.
Phone is completely
handled differently.
How do you make sure if I can
transcribe all my audio calls
into text and then
run some analysis,
there's a huge
opportunity there.
Number two, typically you can
route your customer requests
without even understanding
what's in it.
What if you could
use natural language
to understand and parse what's
being said in the customer
service request?
And the third, if you want to
route your customer service
requests, if you know
if it is about shipping
or if it is about pricing, you
can route it to different CSRs.
Again, huge leap of
improvement in productivity
if you can route
it intelligently.
So those are the opportunities.
So at Google, we have provided
you a set of portfolio,
machine learning
portfolio, that helps you
tackle a lot of these problems.
On the left hand
side, we have what
we call pretrained
machine learning models
where you don't need a data
science degree to actually use
some of these models.
These are RESTful
APIs that you can call
using a single line of code.
And what it helps you
do is understand what's
in a major audio or video.
On the right hand
side of this spectrum
is if you want to
build a custom model
for your own particular need,
if you want to do a text
classifier to route your
tickets differently,
you probably will use an open
source deep learning framework
like TensorFlow and run it
on the Cloud Machine Learning
engine.
And that's the full spectrum
that gives you the opportunity
to build to your need.
So to talk about each of these
key products that are useful,
I'll hand it over to Sara
to walk you to the products.
SARA ROBINSON: Thanks Apoorv.
So I'm going to cover the Cloud
Speech and the Cloud Natural
Language API since
those are particularly
relevant to customer service.
Let's start with the Speech API.
How many of you have
used the OK Google
functionality on your phone?
Anybody here?
Looks like a little
more than half.
So the Speech API essentially
exposes the functionality
of OK Google to
developers, and lets
you do speech to text
transcription in over 80
languages.
So here's an overview of the
features of the Speech API.
You can transcribe text in
over 80 languages and variants.
And it supports both
batch and streaming mode.
So you can send it a
complete audio file.
You can also send it a
stream of continuous audio,
and it'll transcribe the audio
as the stream is coming in.
It can detect inappropriate
content in your audio.
And then you can, once
you've got the text,
you can analyze it with other
Google Cloud Machine Learning
APIs, which I'm going to
talk about momentarily.
So this is what a
request to the Speech API
would look like in Python.
So you create your
service request.
And there's a couple
of different things
you need to pass to Speech API.
You tell it the encoding
type of the audio--
here we're using LINEAR16--
the sample rate in hertz.
And then you pass it
the language code.
If you leave this parameter
out, it'll default to English.
Otherwise if you're using a
language other than English,
you just need to tell it the
language code of the language
you'd like to transcribe.
And then you pass it either
a Google Cloud Storage
URI of your audio file, or
you can give it a local file
to transcribe.
And that's all you have to do.
So the beauty of these
machine learning APIs--
I like to call them
friendly machine learning--
is they give you access to these
pretrained models with just
a single REST API request.
So you don't really
have to understand
what's going on in
the underlying model.
So that's the Speech API.
So with the Speech API,
we're transcribing audio.
Once we get that
text transcription,
we likely don't
want to stop there.
There's probably
more analysis we
want to do on it, especially in
the customer service industry.
Once we get our customer's
call, maybe it's a voice mail,
we're going to want to do
more analysis on that text.
And that's where the Natural
Language API comes into play.
What it does is it lets you
extract entities, sentiment,
and syntax from text.
So I want to take a deeper
dive into those three features
that it lets you do.
So for the entities example,
I'm a big Harry Potter fan.
So I take in this
sentence about JK Rowling
from her Wikipedia page.
And let's see what the
entity extraction end
point will give us back if
we send it this sentence.
So it's able to extract
these five entities.
And it's going to give us
some JSON data on each one.
And one thing you'll
notice here is
that those first three
entities are actually
all the same thing.
They're actually
just different ways
of saying JK Rowling's name.
Robert Galbraith is
actually a pen name
she used for a
later book series.
But I won't get into that.
So they all point
to the same entity.
So for the entity data
we get back the name,
the type of entity it
is-- she's a person--
and then some metadata on her.
So the API won't
necessarily return metadata
if it's an entity that
doesn't have a Wikipedia page.
But in this case,
there definitely
is a Wikipedia page
for JK Rowling.
So it will give
us the MID, which
is an ID that maps to
Google's Knowledge Graph
so that you think you can
then call the Knowledge Graph
API to get more
data on this entity.
And then we get the
Wikipedia URL for her.
And the other JSON
responses looks similar.
For British, it maps
it to a location.
We also get the MID
and the Wikipedia URL.
And notice that the Wikipedia
URL points to the United
Kingdom Wikipedia page.
So if instead the text
said UK or United Kingdom,
it would still point
to the same entity.
And then for Harry
Potter it look similar.
We get the entity
type as location.
That should actually be person.
It's a mistake.
And then it points to Harry
Potter Wikipedia page.
The second thing that
the Natural Language
API lets you do is analyze
the sentiment of something.
So something this is useful
for is customer feedback.
In this case this is
something that might
be on a restaurant review.
The food is excellent.
I would definitely go back.
So it returns two values for
us to understand the sentiment.
The first is magnitude.
And this tells us the overall
strength of the sentiment,
regardless of whether
it's positive or negative.
And this will change based
on the length of the text.
It can range from 0 to infinity.
This text is pretty
short, which is why we get
a pretty small number there.
The score value is going
to tell us whether it's
positive or negative.
So this ranges from
negative 1 to 1.
And we can see that this is
a pretty positive statement.
So it's almost all
the way at one.
And then a final feature
of the Natural Language API
is analyzing syntax.
And this gets a bit more into
the linguistic details of text.
And its visualization
is actually
pulled from the products page
for the National Language API.
So anybody can go
here and try it out,
create a visualization
with your own text
without having to write
any code to get started.
There's a bunch of
data it returns here
on the syntax of your text.
So the sentence we have is
the Natural Language API
helps us understand text.
And lets start with that
top row, those green arrows.
That's what we call a dependency
parse tree, which basically
tells us how the
words in the sentence
relate to each other,
which words depend
on other words in the sentence.
That second row is
the parse label.
And that's basically the role
of each word in a sentence.
So we can see that
helps is the root verb.
API is the nominal subject.
The third row is
just the raw text.
And then that purple
row is what we
call the lemma, which is the
canonical form of a word.
So we can see that
the word is helps,
but the lemma is actually help.
So if you want to
count the occurrences
of a particular word, you
can use the canonical form
so that helps and help don't
count as two different words.
And then in the red row we
get the part of speech--
verb, noun,
adjective, et cetera.
And then finally we got
additional morphology details
on each token in our sentence.
So that's what the syntax
annotation looks like.
So with the Speech and
Natural Language APIs,
they work in many
different cases,
but there may be situations
where your system has
a lot of different custom data,
custom entities that you're
looking for.
And in this case you would
want to use something
to build and train
your own models.
And I'm going to hand
it over to Apoorv forum
to talk about Cloud
Machine Learning Engine.
APOORV SAXENA: Sounds good.
Thank you.
So imagine I was talking about
a customer service request
or customer phone call coming
in, talking really agitated
and saying, hey, my
shipping was not delivered.
So again, using Speech API,
you have transcribed that audio
into text using
sentiment analysis,
using Natural Language API.
You have figured out this
is a very negative comment.
As a result, your
system so far has
identified this is
a very high priority
call that you need to route.
Next thing you need to know is
what kind of requests it is.
Is it a shipping request?
Is it about pricing issue?
It's about support issue,
so on and so forth.
And this is where your
Cloud Machine Learning API--
sorry, the Cloud
Machine Engine comes in.
So to do this classification of
whether a particular request is
a shipping request
or a pricing request,
you will use what we typically
call text classification.
Text classification
is pretty simple.
What you do is look
at the document,
or in this case email or any
audio converted into text,
and classify it into
a label, a predefined
label that you have
relevant to your use case.
So a classic example,
sentiment analysis
essentially is an example
of text classification.
What you're doing is
looking at a document
and classifying that this
is a positive document
or a negative document
in terms of polarity.
Same thing with
document classification.
So you can not only just do a
particular document classified
as one label, you can say
this ticket is about shipping
and pricing, because
a customer can
talk about more than one
subject in a particular email.
So that's the example
of text classification.
And building a text
classifier traditionally
required a pretty
detailed understanding
of the underlying algorithms
and the infrastructure.
With TensorFlow and Cloud
Machine Learning Engine,
all this is simplified
to a significant degree.
A typical text classification
on a customer service
would look like this.
There are two steps involved
in any building any classified.
One is the training step.
Another is the serving step.
In the training step, what
you're doing is you're taking
a set of labelled documents--
in this case it will be service
requests labeled as shipping
or pricing issues or customer
service issues and
so on and so forth.
You feed that and
create a classifier.
And the way you
create a classifier
is basically extract
out key features
that you're creating
the classifier on.
In this case the
feature could be
words or bag of words or
sentence, so on and so forth.
And then you feed
your classifier
and train your model.
And once you have
trained your model,
if you got the results that you
expected in terms of your test
data, you then use
that trained model
on a cloud machine
learning engine
to serve for your
production environment.
In the production environment
it's pretty simple.
You get a new service ticket.
You send it to the classifier
being served on the Cloud
Machine Learning Engine.
Out comes the label, in
this case whether it's
a shipping request or
is a pricing request
and so on and so forth.
So this is-- again, we haven't
gone to typically a text
classifier using TensorFlow
because TensorFlow provides
a set of very
sophisticated libraries
that helps you do
the preprocessing
and the postprocessing
on text very easily.
So I'm hiding a lot
of those details here.
But no more than
80 lines of code
you can build a code classifier.
And so for example in this
case, the very first step
is you can specify
the model you want
to use to build your classifier.
So here in this case,
I'm using a bag of words.
Bag of words doesn't take into
account the order of the words.
So for example, for
shipping requests,
as long as there are words
like shipping, delivery,
date of delivery, and
so on and so forth,
it will classify that request
as a shipping request.
And for pricing, if there are
words of pricing, discounts,
and so on and so forth, that
will use it to classify--
the model will use that to
classify it as a pricing issue.
So that's the very
simplified bag of words.
You can try out different
models as per your need
and the accuracy that you need.
And again, this TensorFlow
allows you to sort of change
the model in very simple ways.
And once you trained,
the first thing once
you've specified the model
to use, you create a model.
And then once you've trained the
model, you run the prediction.
And then typically you will
run this predictive model
or attained model on a Cloud
Machine Learning Engine.
So that's it.
Again, very simple.
You went from step one, Speech
API using Language API and now
tax classification
to route your ticket.
SARA ROBINSON: Thanks Apoorv.
So we've heard
about a few products
that can help us with this.
But to get a really good
understanding of it,
it would be good to see
a real customer use case.
So I'm going to bring
up Dan from Ocado.
Everyone welcome Dan.
Hi Dan.
Dan is the Head
of Data at Ocado.
And he's been in IT
for 20 plus years.
and always been passionate
about data driving businesses
forward.
So Dan, could you
tell us a little bit--
give us some background on
Ocado and explain the problem
you're trying to solve
with machine learning.
DAN NELSON: Sure.
So this slide kind
of says it all.
We're an online supermarket.
We're based only in the
UK, so quite a few of you
probably won't have heard of us.
What it doesn't
tell you is in fact
we're the world's largest
dedicated online grocery
business.
We have about half a
million active customers
and a revenue of $1.5 billion.
We've been around 17 years.
I think that's the
time that Diane
said is an average yesterday,
which was a bit funny,
and have basically
innovated and disrupted
the grocery market in the
UK since our inception.
We actually have a
thousand engineers.
So we're more a
technology company
who run retail and operation
logistics businesses
than a pure play retailer.
And those operations are
kind of part of the model.
We run what we call CFCs,
customer fulfillment centers.
These are large scale
automated warehouses.
By large scale I'm talking
about four football pitches
as a footprint,
four stories high,
with about 20 miles worth of
conveyor belt within them.
They basically take products
from suppliers on pallets,
and then they
distribute them out
at the other end as individual
items for customer orders.
They process about 10
million items a week
and complete an order
every 2 and 1/2 seconds.
And we have two of those, what
we call our kind of legacy ones
now, because as part of
disrupting the industry,
we disrupt ourselves.
And we've recently created
a new model of warehouse.
It operates as a hive, a three
dimensional dense storage
grid with robots running over
the top of it, which basically
give us increased efficiency
and increased accuracy.
And all this technology and
all this operation efficiency
is all because we want
exceptional customer service.
The grocery market is extremely
competitive around the world,
but in the UK especially.
And you need a compelling
offer to the customer
and you need it to be
consistent and reliable,
because if you got it
wrong, they will move.
Our warehouses allow always
to offer a wider range
than anybody else, about
50,000 grocery lines.
And we achieve a 99% fulfillment
rate on that to the customer.
But you know, it
doesn't always work.
And as much as we've applied
machine learning inside
of our warehouses to improve
the way the product flows and is
laid out, and as much as we're
intelligent about segmenting
and personalizing our service,
when we get a customer problem,
it always comes down, as Apoorv
said, to emails or voice.
And when you get to
a scale that we're
at now, dealing with those
emails can be a challenge.
And that's where we hope
machine learning would help us.
SARA ROBINSON: So how are
you using natural language
processing and machine
learning, and specifically
Google Cloud Platform products,
to solve that problem?
DAN NELSON: So this is a
typical contact center-- i.e.
it was our contact center.
An email would come
in from a customer.
It would go behind the
queue, and eventually it
would get to the
front to be processed.
You can see that regardless
of the type of email,
regardless of the importance
and the sentiment,
that queuing system just worked.
Now we get about 2,000 emails
a day into our contact centers,
and we resource our contact
centers to deal with that.
Where it becomes a problem
is if we have a road network
problem--
it's the UK, we
get bad weather--
then actually that
operation can slow down
and the emails can
double, even triple.
And so we wanted to
come up with a way
to basically prioritize so we
could get rid of the queue.
And as Apoorv had
explained, that's
kind of bringing
structure to these emails.
So the idea here--
I love your website.
These are typically
emails I have to say.
I have children so it's easier
for me to do shopping online.
That is classified as feedback.
It's positive.
And that's how we are able
to then take that forward.
Now we used Natural
Language API initially.
And that did some great
work in the classification
and really good in sentiment.
But the structure of our
emails and the language
our customers used
means that we need
a bit more of a bespoke model.
And certainly the
tags we want applying
are very much fitting
to our business.
So as Apoorv had talked
about, we thought, well,
we'll look at using TensorFlow.
We actually store all of our
customer emails as an archive.
We have a corpus of about
3 million emails stored.
They were actually
all stored on-premise.
And before we push
them into GCS,
we had to do a
load of data prep.
We wanted to remove all of the
personally identifiable data.
People do put credit cards,
a bit like the demo today.
People can be a little easy
with their information.
So we ran some preprocessing.
And once that had been
stripped out, we tokenized it.
So we kind of
retained the meaning.
We pushed that into GCS,
and then basically ran
a training of a model.
And once that had been built,
we, as Apoorv had suggested,
put it into Cloud ML.
And it now sits in front
of our contact center,
and in real time,
receives the email,
works out what it believes
the subject matter is,
what the sentiment is, what the
priority is, and then pushes
that back into the queue
in the correct order.
Basically the model is a
convolutional neural network.
We have a word embedding
layer followed by two
parallel convolutional layers.
We have a performance
measure of 0.8.
And the model was trained using
word2vec as an initialization
into the word embedding.
We found that it worked
really well on our corpus.
And so we retained that.
And we trained with a
sigmoid cross entropy lost
over 20 epochs.
SARA ROBINSON: So
how has implementing
all this machine
learning functionality
impacting your business?
And maybe you could
share any lessons you've
learned throughout the process.
DAN NELSON: Yeah, sure.
I was bit quick on the
click there wasn't I.
So we put this in December,
run it in parallel basically
to our normal
contact center queue.
And we got some stock results.
We were four times
quicker at responding
to negatively sentiment flagged
emails than we were responding
to the positive ones.
So that was brilliant.
So there was a definite
distinction and differentiation
there.
And actually as a base level,
we were three times quicker
responding to those
negative emails
than if we hadn't
applied filtering.
So that was fantastic.
Ironically, we haven't
actually had a bad day since.
So we haven't got a measure
for what it does when we spike.
But that was some
fantastic results.
And then as part of
kind of better data,
we actually found out that
about 10% of those emails
don't require any human
interaction at all.
They're kind of things like
thanks, something like that.
And if we auto close
those, then we can save,
redeploy four full
time employees
in the contact center.
It's going to save us sort of
around about 100,000 pounds
a year.
And as the model itself only
costs us 1,000 pounds a year
to run inside of
Cloud ML engine,
that's about a 10,000% ROI.
SARA ROBINSON: That's huge.
DAN NELSON: It's huge.
But those weren't
the only things
that kind of come out for it.
I mean obviously it would have
been great if that was all.
But we did have some key
lessons, as you asked.
Firstly, we learned that we
had to define our success
criteria really well.
This was actually the business
and the development team
for the contact center who
came to us with the problem.
And they were using measures
like time for first response
and things like that.
Actually what we
found is that wasn't
a great measure because
it ignored the sentiment.
It kind of ignored the
long term compounding.
If it's my first issue, does
it stop me shopping-- no.
If it's two or three, yeah.
So we had to work with them
on getting better measures
so we could actually tally if
what we were doing was better.
The other thing we found
is be really careful
when you kind of define
your control groups
and run A/B tests.
When you're playing about
with customer service,
you don't want to
get your test wrong.
And you want to identify as soon
as something might be wrong.
And then the other thing
was the initial feeling
that this was all about
contact center efficiency
and headcount actually
was not borne out either.
By better data, we're
now able to spot
when products are starting
to behave abnormally
from a refund level.
Sometimes that's something
we do operationally
to do with the way we've
received or store product.
If we respond to
that quicker, we
can reduce refunds
going to customers.
Refunds are basically
bad products.
So that's a great
customer service benefit.
And we can also respond
to people going,
I'm not going to be in.
Please cancel.
And that means we can
free up resorts on vans
and use less picking, pick
less product, less waste.
And then the better data
also we can then extend out
into our lapsing model.
We now understand not just you
contacted the contact center,
but it was positive or negative.
It was about a product.
And that helps us build better
lapsing models because now we
know the contact.
But more than anything--
and it's a relatively soft
benefit--
we now really understand how
to build these machine learning
models, how easy it is.
And with the right
kind of thought,
it's kind of opened up
vast opportunities for us
to work on this.
SARA ROBINSON: Definitely.
So what's next for Ocado?
Do you have any future plans
for more machine learning
functionality?
DAN NELSON: Oh yeah, yep.
So this is only the
beginning, really,
the contact center piece.
We'd love to apply this to
social networks as well.
Contact center would love us
to be able to pick up trends
from there.
We want to go more
into conversation
as well, so more
on the speech side.
Could be on the retail side
or from a customer service
point of view.
We're also looking now at
deploying machine learning
models for demand forecasting.
Our forecasting is
great at the minute.
We only have less than
1% of sales as waste.
But we think we can get better.
And so the opportunities are
vast within the operation.
SARA ROBINSON: Great.
Thank you so much for
sharing your use case.
DAN NELSON: You're welcome.
Thank you.
SARA ROBINSON: Thank you.
So next I'd like to
bring up Apoorv and Rajiv
to talk about PwC,
another customer use case.
APOORV SAXENA: [INAUDIBLE] Dan.
This totally changes a
perception of a grocery store,
doesn't it?
How many times do you think
machine learning is being
used in such interesting ways?
And this is unique in a way
because not every customer
that we work with has
a data science team.
And I'm privileged to have a
head of the data science here.
But what if the customer
doesn't have a data science team
and wants to achieve the same
sort of impactful results?
And this is where our
partners such as PwC come in.
So to talk about how customers
are working with PwC to build
an end to end solution,
I'll hand it over to Rajiv
to talk about it.
RAJIV SALIMATH: Thanks Apoorv.
So I'm going to talk about
one of our customers,
Oscar Larson, and how we helped
them with machine learning,
how we helped bring
optimization to their business.
But to set the
expectation, I think
Google has a great
technology stack
across all kinds of things.
And I always joke
with my friends
that you know
Google's stack is good
because it can recognize Indian
names in the voice recognition
thing, which is very hard to do.
And Oscar Larson is a company
that that's a PwC client.
And they service gas stations.
And they run the largest
such service companies.
And they have a huge challenge
across different parts
of their customer
support organization.
They have a
challenge across, how
do you optimize recording
of the calls that
come in from different
gas stations about what
might be down?
How do you make sure that the
field engineers who go out
there have all
the data that they
need, they have all the right
equipment that they need,
the parts, so
they're well-equipped
and they don't have
to do a return trip?
And at the same
time, we also wanted
to analyze how we
solve the problem
that parts and
other such inventory
are not stuck out on the
trucks of these field engineers
and they're using the right
things for the right solutions.
And Larson, as a
company, they wanted
to get a scale from being a
dominant player in five states
to grow across the country.
And what PwC was
able to do was we
were able to bring this
business data to kind of train
the machine learning
algorithms and use the Larson
data, along with
the proprietary data
that we were able to bring,
to build them a solution that
could help them scale.
And the way we did this--
so we kind of, when
you look at the system
that we built for Larson,
essentially every time
a new call comes in
at the left side,
and initially we
first try to extract
whatever useful
concept and entities
that we can extract from there.
It's a little bit
like one of the slides
that Sara had earlier where
we use the Google Cloud NLP
API to extract whatever
concepts we can get.
And we also want to
extract whatever sentiments
that we can extract from them.
It's slightly different
from a problem
of trying to disambiguate
whether JK Rowling is
the right author or
not when you have
to deal with statements
like, hey, my pump is down.
It is a positive
sentiment statement.
But you have to try to
analyze, why is the pump down?
What could the problems be?
And that's what I'm going
to show you is a demo.
So to analyze the
problem that comes in,
we take all of the data that
we have access to from Larson.
They get over 50,000
support calls a year.
And they've been doing
this for over 10 years.
So there's a huge data set
that was available for us
to use as training data.
And we also look at what
parts were actually sold
to the customers to
fix different issues.
And so we know that
a problem came in,
a certain part was
used to fix it.
And we use that as
training data to figure out
for future problems what kind
of parts might be relevant.
And using that, the ML
system that we built,
it recommends three solutions.
Anytime somebody
calls into Larson
and says there's a
problem, it figures out
who's the most qualified
engineer, who's
the engineer who knows how
to fix that type of fuel pump
or that type of point
of sale terminal.
It figures out, what are the
right manuals and documents
that he might need on the
ground to refer quickly
to fix that issue?
And we have all of those
stored in Google Drive.
And the machine learning
automatically, in real time,
links these Google
Docs to the context.
And the last part, which
leads to the most cost saving
for Larson, is how it recommends
the most relevant parts.
I'll show a quick demo of this.
If I can switch over
to the other screen?
APOORV SAXENA: So
[INAUDIBLE] right now.
RAJIV SALIMATH: Yeah, well we
Indians have as many machine
learning experts as we
have gas station owners.
So for this context let's
assume Apoorv is a gas station
guy who really doesn't know much
about what the problem could
be in his gas station.
And this is what 90% of the
problems that the Larson
customer support team looks at.
They could get a
problem as simple
as something like just
my pumps are down.
And in most cases,
these people don't
know how to describe
anything more than that.
They have no clue
what makes up a pump.
I've had an education in
this in the last six months.
I've been forced to study this.
But most people don't know.
So the system figures out
from a historic pattern
of all of the problems.
And it does Cloud MLP on the
fly to first figure out, hey,
all the pumps are down.
Are they down on diesel
pumps, unleaded pumps?
It tries to get
some more context.
And if I say, for example, all
pumps are down on unleaded,
and then it
understands that, hey,
if it's a problem
with just one pump,
then it's probably something
to do with parts that
make up a specific fuel pump.
And then it looks at things
like breakaways and hoses
and things like that.
But if it's something to
do with a lot of pumps,
then it's probably something
to do with communication
to the pump, a motor,
something like that.
So at first it picks up--
it also has a Google Map
API integrated with it.
So it picks up the location.
It picks up where
Apoorv is calling from.
He's definitely not
calling from New York,
but that's a real gas
station in New York.
And once he confirms
his location,
it picks up what
type of gas pumps
there are in that location.
And then it diagnoses
the issue to say
that it's probably something to
do with the motor or a filter.
And it now sends
this information
to the field engineer who's
been assigned to that case.
It also picks a
field engineer who
is equipped in fixing motor
or filter types of issues.
And I can show you
a little bit more
under the covers of
what's happening.
So this is a simple
representation
of the recommendation
engine that we've built.
And so when that chatbot
looks at the back end,
it first tries to
figure out, what's
the equipment on that site?
And then based on
recommending the issues--
let me just refresh this.
So it first analyzes that
particular site and figure out
what type of equipment
there is on that site.
And once it understands
that, it goes on
to try to analyze the problem.
And this is we're
using TensorFlow.
And we have a single
layered neural network
to-- we created a single
to solve that problem.
And once it figures
out what could
be the different equipment that
could be causing the fault,
it creates a simple Bayesian
probability analysis of that,
and then assesses
that it's probably
due to a motor or
a filter fault.
Then the hardest
part of this product
was to try to figure out
what's the right part that
could solve that issue.
And this is something
that we're picking out
of literally several
thousand parts on the fly.
And once it finds
the right part,
it also recommends
the right documents
that that field engineer
would need to refer
to fix that issue on site.
We can come back to the slide.
APOORV SAXENA: So
I think one thing
I'm sure the audience
want to know,
what is the
infrastructure and what
are the technology
choices PwC made in sort
of building the solutions?
So could you tell more about it?
RAJIV SALIMATH: Yeah sure.
So this is what our
architecture looks like.
And we chose GCP primarily
because a lot of the tools
that we needed--
we've tried a lot
of different tools.
And for example, if you look
at the bottom of that slide
where we have all of the
NLP and ML components--
so we used the
Natural Language API
and we used the Cloud Machine
Learning API, and TensorFlow.
And when we have a lot of these
call records, a lot of these
are not entered
in full sentences.
These are field engineers
who are entering stuff
on their phone.
It's broken language.
It's a lot of code
words and item numbers
and part names and
things say that.
So it's very hard to
process that type of data
with just a natural
language processing.
And because there's a good
tethering between the NLP
API, the machine learning,
and creating a neural network
and executing it on TensorFlow
in the Google framework,
we chose that platform.
And on the right side, you
can see the legacy data,
which is the data set that
Larson had for over 10 years.
And we migrated that data
to essentially a Cloud SQL
database.
And we used Firebase on top
of it, along with BigQuery,
to create indexes
that we can query.
And the front end
is all built as--
we have different apps
for the dispatcher.
We have apps for the call center
people, field tech people.
These are all Android
apps which all access
code through App Engine.
The reason we chose
GCP was it really
provided all the elements we
needed, from the front end
to the back end to the
machine learning piece.
APOORV SAXENA: Thank you.
So to wrap it up, I think,
as you can see, if you are--
if you--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So as you can see, if you are a
customer who has a data science
expertise in-house,
you can directly
use our products as is.
If you want to build
an end to end solution,
you can work with our
SI partners such as PwC
to build an end to end solution
tailored to your needs.
So in terms of
external resources,
these are the places where
you can find more information.
[MUSIC PLAYING]